My goodness, today might be a historic day,
because Google DeepMind’s ChatGPT competitor,
Gemini is here.
We were wondering what kind of secret AI does
google have up its sleeve, and today, you
will know all about it.
I am so excited, and I was also surprised
by this appearing as I was catching up on
some music albums to listen to, and found
a new favorite song with the same name, what
are the chances!
So, what can the Gemini AI do?
Boy, did they come out with guns blazing.
Thus, Gemini has a lot to offer.
According to the marketing materials, it is
absolutely insane, and fortunately, look!
Yes!
Haha!
We also have a paper to have a look at together.
This is a multimodal AI, it can have a look
at your math homework, with handwritten notes,
no need to type in anything, just a photo,
and look!
It already found a silly little mistake in
this physics derivation.
It explains what went wrong and how to do
it right beautifully.
It can even give you new practice problems
and analyze your answers to that.
A personal teacher.
That is amazing.
But note that ChatGPT can do this too.
We’ll see in a moment if it can do things
that ChatGPT cannot.
And we are not done yet.
Not even close.
In fact, we are just warming up.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now, have a look at this paper.
This is a meta analysis on different genetic
variants of particular diseases.
This means a research paper, written by hand
by looking up tens of thousands and thousands
of papers, finding the handful of papers out
of those that have relevant information to
a given topic, aggregate and compare their
findings, and draw a conclusion.
That is a herculean task.
And now, hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because Gemini can do this automatically.
It can evaluate papers rapidly, and see how
relevant they are.
Now, little AI, read the paper and extract
the relevant data from it.
Look!
No hallucinations allowed, because we are
seeing where it got all this data from.
According to DeepMind, it read through hundreds
of thousands of papers in just one lunch break.
I have to say they have incredibly productive
lunch breaks over there at DeepMind.
Bravo!
Now it can also update the studies and the
fact that this is a multimodal AI, it means
that it can deal with code, audio, images,
video, you name it.
Not just text.
Fantastic.
But wait a second, if it can do all of that,
is it possible that it can even write a paper?
Interesting question.
Well, little AI, update the graphs with the
new information.
Wow!
So far, we needed this kind of herculean effort
to summarize this genetic research data up
to 2019, and now, we have all this data up
to 2023.
And all this in just one lunch break.
Automatically.
And AlphaCode 2 is also here.
The first version was roughly as good as half
the humans in coding, and now, better than
85% of the human competitors.
All this in just one version change.
So, what can it do?
Well, it can break down a written task, and
come up with efficient solutions.
Here, it came up with a solution using dynamic
programming, this is a college-level computer
science algorithm that breaks down a big,
difficult problem into smaller, easier problems.
Such a short, elegant solution.
And make no mistake, this is not just coding.
This is reasoning, understanding, and synthesis.
Loving it.
And now, you can have this incredible digital
mind as a companion, or even as a teacher
in your journeys.
And by double-checking and repairing its own
answers, it can now write you a web app in
less than a minute.
It is not going to be perfect, but it is an
incredible first crack at a problem.
Once again, ChatGPT can likely do this too
for you at least as well.
Now I promised that we will see if it can
do things that ChatGPT cannot.
So, can it?
Well, it is advertised as a universal AI,
let’s talk about that and compare to ChatGPT
because there are absolutely insane insights
there.
They showcase incredible performance on the
MMLU dataset.
When I heard this, my eyes basically popped
out of my head.
So what does this mean?
This is the Massive Multitask Language Understanding
dataset.
It contains questions about anatomy, astronomy,
chemistry, formal logic, marketing, management,
sociology, virology, you name it.
So, how good is it?
Well, this is a good human performance, and
this is Gemini.
Yup.
That sort of means superhuman performance.
Now this graph is from the marketing materials,
but we are Fellow Scholars here, we like research
papers better, so there you go.
Ah, much better.
Now let’s look at the comparison.
Yes, it claims to beat ChatGPT, but this comparison
has its limits.
ChatGPT was benchmarked with 5-shot, which
means that the AI was given 5 somewhat similar
examples to learn from, where Gemini’s CoT
stands for Chain of Thought.
These are important details.
This means guiding the AI model through a
step by step reasoning process.
This is not entirely the same process at the
5 shot.
But it gets better!
Beyond that, in 30 of 32 benchmarks it came
in first.
And many of these comparisons are apples to
apples comparisons, you can see the equivalent
number of shots in the comparisons on many
datasets.
With this, I think it is fair to conclude
that on these datasets, yes, it can do things
that ChatGPT cannot.
I told you, Google is coming with guns blazing.
And wait, if we can have this kind of universality
in an AI… do you remember the example with
the genome data?
Yes!
This means that it can do this in any area
of science.
Any topic.
Same with the math lessons.
Any lesson works.
My goodness!
And Gemini comes in three sizes:
Ultra - this is for the hardest of the hardest
tasks, pro, this is the bread and butter for
most tasks, and nano, this is a tiny version
for you to be able to run it in your pocket.
Yes, right on your phone.
The Pixel 8 Pro is the first smartphone to
be able to run this.
Now, good news, I’ll tell you in a moment
how you can try it, but first, two insane
things from the paper:
One, the training took place across multiple
data centers.
Depending on the methodology, that would possibly
require a computer network that is so fast
that it basically makes my head fall off.
That is incredible.
Two, look at this.
This is something that I could not believe
for years, but it is here, and it is true.
Specialist AIs exist, these are techniques
that are incredibly good at one thing, but
cannot really do anything else.
Like AlphaGo at Go, or AlphaFold at protein
folding.
And then, there are generalist AIs like GPT-4
and Gemini.
These can do a lot of things, but not as well
as the specialist AI can do the one thing.
Until now.
And this is a historic moment - this is a
universal AI that can beat these specialist
AIs at their own game.
Perhaps because knowing a little less about
your area, but more about the world in general
makes you a better specialist.
That is incredible.
A huge philosophical thought that keeps me
up at night.
So much to think about!
So, when can we try it?
Well, according to Google, right about now!
According to them, the pro version is available
right now in Bard.
However, not for me as of the making of this
video, so I am assuming there is a staggered
rollout of this system.
Likely, it will gradually be deployed to all
of us very soon.
I will note that we do not have any business
ties with Google or DeepMind or OpenAI.
None of our videos were sponsored by them,
including this one of course.
According to what we hear from internal documents,
getting this AI and Bard right might be an
existential issue for Google, so they are
putting all their might into it.
And I have to say it shows.
Wow.
Very excited to give this a try soon, and
if you see this video, make sure to try Google
Bard, it might already be infused by Gemini
by the time you are watching this.
The link is in the video description.
What a time to be alive!
And if you enjoyed this and if you wish to
see more, become a Fellow Scholar by subscribing
and hitting the bell icon.
Checking out our sponsor is also a great way
to support us.
Thank you so much!